despite President Donald Trump sounding
off on China he's kind of stuck with
them while the US and China may have
different values and styles of
governance they actually have a lot of
common interests so here are three
reasons why Trump isn't going to break
up with China even though he kind of
said he would let's start with the
biggest most obvious reason the economy
the US and China are incredibly
interdependent importing one-fifth of
what the other exports from China we're
talking machinery furniture toys your
new iPhone and from the u.s. to China
goods include food airplanes and cars
and raw materials in 2015 US exports to
China totaled 113 billion dollars but
it's not just stuff that you or I might
buy Chinese banks have invested in u.s.
debt and they are the single largest
owner of it in the Wars of the Chinese
president if we are in confrontation it
will surely spell disaster for both
countries and the wider world which
brings us to reason number two military
cooperation there's that thing about the
world's two biggest economies having the
two biggest armies and it's critical
that these two nuclear nations keep the
peace
drink President Barack Obama's
administration the two collaborated to
contain North Korea and work to hash out
cyber security goals Obama's approach to
China was delicate like a partner he
needed but didn't fully trust Trump's
approach is actually quite the opposite
he appointed economist Peter Navarro to
lead the new national trade council
who's a harsh critic of trade with a
country and he's also the author of this
book and as with any frenemy there's
going to be drama specifically in the
South China Sea where tensions have been
heating up it's one of the world's most
crucial waterways and there are an
estimated 11 billion barrels of oil
under the scene oh and all six countries
in the region claimant so when Beijing
called dibs and sent in their military
the u.s. started patrolling the waters
to be like hey slow down so we got
trillions of dollars military's future
oil reserves and egos really baked egos
and reason number three that the United
States and China aren't breaking up the
US isn't so lonely at the top anymore
China and Russia have stepped in where
American influence has weakened because
frankly imposing democracy and global
South policing can get
expensive and the US can't afford to
break up with the country that's taken
an active role in its own backyard Latin
America it's worth noting Russia and
China are taking the lead with their
global Development Goals Russia in the
Middle East and China and Africa and
Latin America while the two aren't
exactly the best of friends
they have been collaborating since the
end of the Cold War China is Russia's
largest trading partner and the
countries collaborate on extensive
projects like a pipeline to bring
Russian gas to the communist state
if Trump turns his back on China that
means putting the United States up
against both Russia and China and
threatening the country's economic
stability meaning it's in u.s. global
and economic interest to keep engaged
with China because when the new global
order shakes out the u.s. doesn't want
to be on the sidelines so don't expect
Chinese American relations to disappear
anytime soon